here's the first story we got from The
Washington Post Ukraine denies kremlin's
claim of drone assassination attempt on
Putin now we have this video that was uh
posted by the times on YouTube I'm gonna
play the clip for you I don't think
there's any audio and uh you just see a
uh weird little object fly in and then
blow up
and that's it
so it exploded over the building and uh
I guess what happened was they they
destroyed it before I mean you're not
gonna get a drone into the Kremlin I
mean they've got air defenses according
to Washington Post they say Russia on
Wednesday accused Ukraine of staging a
drone attack intending intended to kill
Vladimir Putin the Kremlin
an incendiary allegation that was
forcefully denied by Ukrainian officials
some of whom warned it could be a
pretext for Russia to escalate the war
it is it absolutely is whether or not
it's a false flag whether or not Ukraine
actually did it there's video they
claimed it happen and that's what you're
going to see some kind of escalation
some kind of justification perhaps it's
Vladimir Putin trying to Rally public
support in his country to for the
ongoing war or because he wants to turn
the heat up and use more advanced
weapons or something like that and he
needs some kind of justification or
maybe Ukraine just tried to do it maybe
maybe it could be an Insurgent faction
it could be a group of Ukraine who knows
but I wouldn't put it past them I do
kind of think this was crude and poorly
done so it's probably I don't know I'd
assume more was a false flag yeah first
I heard there were two drones and that
they were brought down by Russian uh
like countermeasures and so that was the
Drone actually coming down as a result
of the Russian interference so that but
I don't know if that was true or not
either I mean
they released a statement saying it was
too unmanned aerial uh two drones
apparatuses and they also said you know
we have uh May 9th which is our Victory
Day we we celebrate the end or when
Germany fell to the Soviet Union and so
this is lining up on sort of to be an
attack on our our national pride
basically this is this is basically the
White House it's like the Russian
version of The White House Washington
Post says it's the working residence of
Vladimir Putin but to fly a drone I mean
the explosion was very small compared to
the building just to aim a thing into
the top of the Kremlin I don't see how
that would get put maybe they knew where
they were headed and they were trying to
go right into his office
even there they said that this he wasn't
even there what kind of drone was it is
the question was it a small you know
commercial consumer drone or something
or was it you know an American
military-style Reaper or whatever it was
a loaded with explosives or was that
just the machine itself being blown
apart yo I warned about this 10 years
ago this is crazy to see happen I was uh
I was doing research in 2011 on drone
stuff and when I it was about 2014 I
think I actually went to the um what is
it the Northwestern drone Coalition a
group of uh universities were working
with the government and news
organizations to figure out what are we
doing about this new technology and when
I went and met with these University
people I outright told them your biggest
concern is probably security because
someone's going to take one of these
things they're going to arm it and
they're going to fly it straight into a
city and there is nothing you can do at
that point at that point your question
is where does it blow up not if it will
and swarm technology is the next level
right now now we're seeing in in Ukraine
these small commercial style drones and
military ones but that are small
carrying explosives and payloads
swarming and just peppering targets and
stuff like that you'll need like a laser
defense system where like there's a
pylon that if there's like 10 000 drones
all coming that the thing will like
spark out 10 000 shocks and hit them all
at once and knock them all down I don't
think you can't stop them individually
it's not going to be able to move fast
enough if they did some kind of laser
defense system I think that could work
so uh you would need a high-powered
laser but it's not going to be well it
could theoretically move fast enough but
to transfer enough energy from the from
the laser to the Drone to disable it
might take more than than just a second
you would need huge amounts of energy
for that it would it would point at it
hold for about a second and probably
take it out of the sky instantly
scramble it up heat it up overheat it
but if there's 10 000 of these drones or
even a few hundred of them this laser is
not going to be able to stop all of them
what vibe did you get James about this
whole thing there's so much that we
don't know and our primary source of
information about it we have to remember
is the Kremlin right so even the video
itself it's intriguing to me that we're
being allowed to see it why would
um the Russians release video of what
they're claiming was a almost a
successful attack on the Kremlin right
benefits them well maybe
um
so be that as it may first our only
source of information is a very
unreliable one okay
um as to the question of whether this
could be the pretext for an escalation
whether it was a false flag or a genuine
Ukrainian attack the Russians haven't
shown throughout this entire uh conflict
that they need any particular pretext to
escalate the whole the war itself is an
enormous escalation right there was no
conflict so I don't think they
particularly need any any staged events
or even a real event to claim as a
justification for for escalation and the
fact is too that the the Russian
military throughout this conflict has
been so shockingly
ineffective that I'm not sure that what
what escalations they can even
successfully Mount beyond the obvious
one that we all worry about which is the
introduction of some kind of nuclear
conventional or tactical convention or
or or
Genuine nuke size nuclear escalation I
don't think they're going to go there
and so
um uh the one thing I would say about
this is it brings up this this posture
of the United States throughout this
conflict which is that we are not
encouraging or enabling
the Ukrainian Armed Forces to launch
attacks inside Crimea or Russia itself
and the question is why not wouldn't the
war be over much more swiftly if
Vladimir Putin and the ruling class in
Russia were made to pay those kinds of
prices the very prices the ukrainians
themselves are paying they want to avoid
Total War they're seeking a limited war
in eastern Ukraine they don't want Putin
to get killed they don't want zelinsky
to get killed because then it's Joe
Biden's on the line so I think this is I
honestly think this is a way for the
Russians to establish grievances in the
global community and be like see now we
have a little bit of justification if we
do decide to go after zielinski so
zelinski you better run and he's like in
Finland right now or something and he
decided to stay I think he's uh he's up
in Nordic country I just want to say if
this really was a false flag it is the
saddest and most pathetic we've seen I
mean you've got the the burning of the
reichstag which many people believe was
a false flag to justify expansion of war
and things like that and that was
literally burning the whole thing to the
ground this is like a little explosion
overhead that didn't do much damage at
all and Putin wasn't even there so I'm
not I'm not sure what they get out of
this really and so some people I already
seen the Super Chat are pointing out
that there's no way those drones flew
400 500 kilometers to make it there so
what what is this the High Altitude
reconnaissance drones maybe they just
got brought down by some sort of
magnetic we're going to have to I'm
sorry go ahead
um we're just gonna have to acclimate
ourselves to the reality that we're not
going to learn all that we would wish to
learn about this event uh but just to
your point before about uh you know the
reason why the U.S is just not
encouraging or enabling uh Ukrainian
Armed Forces to to strike inside Russian
territory is because they fear World War
III but it just seems to me you're
already in a kind of a proxy war to
begin with right
um and
um it's a strange way to Sue War making
if your every decision is going to be
governed by fear of the opponent
escalating the conflict aren't they
enabling isn't the US enabling by
funding this war though I mean we send
materials and supplies to we are the war
so we are saying oh we're not enabling
it but we are well in other words uh I
don't know whether the particular weapon
systems that we've been supplying would
enable uh the Ukrainian Armed Forces to
to do damage inside territorial Russia
um probably there's a suite of weapon
systems we could Supply that would
guarantee the ability of the ukrainians
to uh to to pursue war on Russian
targets but again sort of an ambiguous
line we're saying we're not sure it
could but and radically but but they
don't need to agree with you they don't
need full-scale Warfare weapons from us
to engage in Conflict on Russian
territory in Russian territory in fact
that would probably be the least
effective thing to do the most effective
thing to do is what that lady did when
she brought the statue to that blogger
and blew him up
like Insurgency style targeted guerrilla
warfare disrupting the economy I mean
they're not gonna there's nothing
they're gonna have that's gonna be able
to do enough damage to it to these areas
and if they did open strike on a Russian
city would be a total annihilation of
every Ukrainian major city by the
Russian Air Force it was just overnight
it would just be Total War the entire
country would be leveled to the ground
if they started attacking Russian cities
this is the crazy thing to me about this
whole thing the the the restraint you
see in war makes no sense like you you
Ukraine could easily have more of these
assassinations with the with the statue
for you you guys know about that story
first heard of it for those that don't
know there was this uh I guess it was it
was a vlog a vlogger he was a guy who
would make you know who propagandize in
favor of Russia and he was given us a
bust of himself and it exploded killing
him and injuring several others these
are the kinds of attacks taking out key
targets that are are easier and more
effective in terms of destabilizing you
know uh and they instill Terror main
right exactly the populace wants to know
well where's the next place that could
be struck and strictly but but what you
were saying Ian was that if ukrainians
did use U.S granted or NATO weapon Grant
uh granted weapons of war on a Russian
city Russia would retaliate with
full-scale air strikes my question is
why why don't they do it now because
they want to own the country I don't
think that I think they really want
trade out of this they want to be a
richer country after this war is over
them before it started so they're trying
to take Eastern ukrainees to the dawn
bass run those freeways down to Crimea
and just start shipping steel out into
the Mediterranean and I do I do want to
stress there are U.S boots on the ground
that was confirmed in the in the leaks
that came out a while ago plus there's
there's several other European countries
that have boots on the ground and Hannah
Claire's point is is true which is what
distinction are you really making when
um on the one hand you're saying well we
we are proceeding very carefully up the
S each step up the escalatory ladder so
as not to trigger a you know an
unwelcome escalation from Mr Putin but
you know five minutes later in the same
news conference you're saying our the
the the the weapons and the training
that we're providing are killing Russian
soldiers are causing all these
extraordinary casualties that the
Russians are are absorbing so in essence
you're posting about the very thing that
you're claiming not to be doing but
realistically I think you know
utilitarianly that they care a lot less
about losing humans than they do about
losing infrastructure you blow up
buildings that's going to piss them off
a lot more than killing a bunch of dudes
but again overpopulation at what point
should the should the wet the entire
Western Alliance be governed by fear of
whether uh this particular leader is
going to go nuclear you know does he not
also subscribe to Mad some mutually
assured destruction which govern
relations between the US and the Soviet
Union for 50 years I think that's fake
what's fake mutually assured destruction
in my opinion is uh completely over
hyped and confused by the average person
for some because people tend to simplify
things and because their views are based
off of pop culture and not actual
history they think things like you know
uh gunshots they don't know what they
really sound like they think uh you know
it's like that movie Last Action Hero
remember that Schwarzenegger and Jamie
Lee Curtis he shoots the taxi in the
reality he lives in the movie but then
he comes to the real world and he shoots
the car but nothing happens because in
movies shoot a card explodes like for no
reason thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time